[Musique]
bonsoir à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
dans le journal de tv 78 voici les
titres de ce mercredi 16 décembre en
cette période de crise sanitaire on
parle beaucoup de crise économique alors
la pandémie mondiale va t'elle accentuer
le surendettement des ménages
nous parlerons de ce sujet avec pauline
dujardin chargée de mission et juristes
pour la fédération française des
associations crésus qui accompagnent les
particuliers pour gérer leur budget les
entreprises elles aussi ont des
difficultés financières
nous ferons le point sur le centre
d'information sur la prévention qui aide
les professionnels à s'en sortir dans
l'actualité également il y a un en
ile-de-france mobilité a lancé son offre
de location de vélos électriques
hier lors d'une visioconférence ils ont
dévoilé leur nouveau modèle de deux
roues enfin en remplacement des
traditionnels féerie la ville de trappes
organise pendant trois jours l'événement
tous aux fenêtres pour fêter la fin
d'année
[Musique]
aujourd'hui nous allons donc parler
surendettement un phénomène qui touche
aussi bien les particuliers que les
entreprises
à ce sujet nous accueillons pauline
dujardin bonsoir bonsoir est la
bienvenue
vous êtes donc chargé de mission et
juriste au sein de la fédération
française des associations crésus crésus
je le rappelle a donc trois missions
principales le traitement mais aussi la
prévention du surendettement et le
microcrédit personnel
vous intervenez auprès des particuliers
alors tout d'abord pauline dujardin est
ce que la crise sanitaire a fragilisé
les ménages en ile-de-france alors ce
qu'on peut constater aujourd'hui dans
pendant la crise sanitaire c'est que
finalement on a eu un équilibre il ait
eu des dépenses en moins qui ont pu
compenser les ressources en moins
finalement les dispositifs qui ont été
mis en place que ce soit par l'état
notamment avec la mise en place du
chômage partiel ou par les organismes
bancaires qui ont accordé des reports
d'échéances ont permis de tenir le choc
et donc y at il une baisse ou une
augmentation des personnes on va dire
surendettés vraiment le cas extrêmes en
france depuis cette crise sanitaire
aujourd'hui on n'a pas beaucoup de
visibilité parce que les chiffres sont
trompeurs en effet si vous regardez les
chiffres de dépôt de dossier de
surendettement
il y a eu une baisse considérable
pendant le confinement et ces chiffres
sont trompeurs parce que ce n'est pas
parce que les gens mener des plus en
état de surendettement mais parce qu'ils
ne savaient pas qu'ils pouvaient déposer
des dossiers de surendettement et nous
c'est également ce qu'on a constaté au
sein de deux de nos associations 1
on n'a pas eu encore d'explosion des
contacts des particuliers liés à leur
situation
alors justement vous parlez de situation
dans quelle situation faute il se
trouvait pour faire appel à crésus donc
je le rappelle fédération française
d'associations qui se donne donc rhésus
il faut venir nous voir et il faut venir
voir les associations lorsque vous
commencez à ressentir les des problèmes
financiers
ce n'est pas la peine et il ne faut pas
attendre d'avoir le couteau sous la
gorge pour venir parce que parfois on a
l'impression qu'on va pouvoir s'en
sortir on lève un peu cool et les choses
et c'est là que plusieurs portes se
ferment alors que si on avait pris le
dossier
plus tôt on aurait peut-être plus pu
éviter le surendettement est passé par
d'autres procédures par exemple de
demander des délais de paiement auprès
du juge ou au ou voir agir sur le budget
en prévention
alors je veux citer quelques permanences
dans le département des yvelines
l'association crésus ile-de-france donc
cette fois ci on va dire la fédération
l'association pardon ile-de-france donc
de crésus elle compte 18 permanence dans
une quinzaine de communes du département
ces permanences sont ouvertes à tous et
des conseillers spécialisés sont
disponibles sur rendez-vous pour aider à
gérer le budget c'est ce que vous disiez
vous pouvez en voir donc quelques-unes
sur la carte comme versailles mantes la
jolie ou encore à trappes pour plus
d'informations de toutes façons rendez
vous sur le site de l'association crésus
alors pauline du jardin à quel moment se
considère tout comme surendettées
c'est lorsqu'on n'arrive plus à faire
face à ses charges et à ses crédits dans
cette situation il faut aller consulter
pour qu'un bénévole de l'association
puisse faire un diagnostic et voit où
est le problème
est-ce qu'on peut uniquement agir sur le
budget ouvert ce qu'il faut constituer
éventuellement un dossier de
surendettement et l'association sera là
pour vous accompagner dans chaque
procédure préconisée alors des questions
pauline du jardin c'est une information
qui est tombée aujourd'hui l' ufc que
choisir s'inquiète du niveau record
d'endettement des ménages français est
particulièrement qu'ils soient incités à
prendre des prêts en cette période de
crise sanitaire des crédits à la
consommation et c est justement ces
prêts ces crédits ne sont ainsi pas un
des facteurs d'un futur surendettement
mais également deuxième question est est
ce que les organismes qui accordent ces
prêts ne sont pas aussi un peu fautif
la difficulté c'est l'absence d'
équilibre dans l'information nous c'est
crésus on se bat pour un fichier positif
des crédits qui permettent
et à chaque organisme de crédit de
vérifier l'endettement des particuliers
avant d'en accorder aujourd'hui ce
fichier n'existe pas et lorsqu'on est
pris dans cette spirale du
surendettement
on peut être tenté effectivement de ne
pas donner forcément les bonnes
informations pour pouvoir obtenir
obtenir les crédits
quant à la crise sanitaire aujourd'hui
les entreprises sont sous perfusion
par contre on attend premier semestre de
l'année 2021 beaucoup de licenciements
est effectivement à ce moment là les
crédits vont poser un problème parce que
les gens de corrompus les rembourser
parce qu'ils n'auront plus les mêmes les
mêmes ressources et et nous ce qu'on
attend c'est que tout le monde se mette
autour de la table tout l'écosystème les
associations les organismes bancaires et
l'état pour trouver des solutions
ensemble
comme il a pu être trouvée pour les
entreprises dans le cadre de cette crise
sanitaire
merci paul dujardin d'avoir été avec
nous sur ce plateau flavien maurelet par
d'autres marveaux on vient de parler des
particuliers mais les entreprises elles
aussi peuvent se retrouver dans une
situation de surendettement
justement avec la crise sanitaire de
plus en plus d'entreprises ont des
difficultés financières
le centre d'information sur la
prévention des difficultés des
entreprises
les accompagnent et essaye de trouver
des solutions
reportage de célia gars de son goût
cette société de location de matériel
audiovisuel dédié à l'événementiel a vu
son activité arrêtée dès le 1er
confinement
tout le matériel d'or sur les étagères
puisqu'il n'y a plus de réunions
possibles sur 10 appels faits y avait
10 de vie fait pratiquement huit
affaires conclues et tout s'est arrêté
net à partir du 14 mars
plus aucune affaire plus aucun dossier
un plan social a donc dû être mise en
place sur 47 salariés 20 postes ont été
supprimés ainsi qu'une antenne à
toulouse leur chiffre d'affaires a été
divisé par deux en 2019 il avait réalisé
12 millions d'euros seulement 7 millions
en 2020 pour continuer une certaine
activité les salariés ont créé en studio
de 180 m² avec un mur de l'aide dans
leur partie de dépôt pour pouvoir le
proposer à la location
ici vous avez un grand écran led qui
permet de faire de la communication
des entreprises leur communication
interne vous avez derrière mais le
plateau caméra et nous en voyons tout ça
sur le sur internet par le biais du
streaming avec une plateforme digitale
ce sont des nodal les salariés par le
biais de cette plateforme
vous récupérez les flux de
visioconférence par exemple et ça c'est
là la solution rang entre eux pour
pallier avec les amours est ce que ça
marche plutôt bien et on a d'excellents
retours de nos clients mais cela ne
suffira pas pour payer toutes les
charges
la société a donc fait appel aux séries
p le centre d'information sur la
prévention des difficultés des
entreprises ont rendez vous avec trois
professionnels dont un ancien juge du
tribunal de commerce de versailles hall
aura exposé notre notre situation
ils nous ont donné des conseils qu'on a
appliqué ces entretiens ont mis les deux
jeudis par mois en général 50 entretiens
ont été réalisés en une année en 2020 il
y en a eu plus de 80 en 2001 j'avais
vraiment un boucher persuadé qu'il va y
avoir un boom ladder notre pays en
difficulté mais quand il y avait quand
ils ont commencé à faire leurs premiers
bilans et leurs premières prévisions de
trésorerie mais que ça va tomber dans le
rouge
forcément ils vont d'un nouveau la série
p prévoit déjà d' instaurer des rendez
vous supplémentaire en 2021 pour gérer
l'afflux des entreprises en difficulté
on prend maintenant la direction de la
ville de plaisir cela fait des années
qu'un mur puis une porte vitrée bloquent
le passage entre la passerelle de la
galerie commerciale d'auchan et le
nouveau centre commercial mon grand
plaisir malgré l'avis favorable de la
commission sécurité
un litige entre les deux parties
continuent de bloquer l'ouverture
mais depuis hier la mère de plaisir
joséphine coleman ce berger a obtenu sa
réouverture partielle pour que les
habitants puissent transiter vers la
gare en attendant le règlement du litige
la passerelle est donc ouverte depuis
aujourd'hui entre 9 7 heures et 9 heures
le matin et le soir entre 19h et 20h
dans l'actualité également le conseil
régional d'ile-de-france examiner le
budget pour l'année 2000 21
un budget qui se chiffre à 5 milliards
d'euros la région investit notamment
dans le transport 1,8 milliard d'euros
un volet a aussi été consacrée à la
crise sanitaire avec un plan pour
l'hôpital un milliard d'euros ils seront
investis entre 2020 et 2022
cela servira notamment à financer la
formation dans les instituts en soins
infirmiers développer la recherche
médicale ou encore accompagner et
soutenir les soignants en créant par
exemple des y est enfin en ce qui
concerne la culture 109 millions d'euros
viennent d'être votés pour ce domaine
avec comme priorité soutenir le
développement culturel et reconduire les
aides exceptionnelles liées aux côtés de
19 autres budgets 2021 votée récemment
celui du conseil d'administration de
l'établissement public
interdépartemental entre les yvelines et
les hauts de seine
il s'est réuni hier pour établir les
prévisions budgétaires
l' enveloppe prévue pour les
investissements restent constantes
on fait le point avec justin brasier il
s'est tenu ce mardi 15 décembre au
programme les prévisions budgétaires
pour l'année à venir alors il n'y a pas
plus de dépenses engagées par rapport à
l'année dernière puisque le budget
global de 1021 s'élève à 16,2 millions
d'euros prévus contre 16,3 en 2000
1 ce budget on le rappelle ne se
substitue pas aux budgets départementaux
le pays
yves in hauts-de-seine permet de
réaliser des économies grâce à une
mutualisation des services à une mise en
commun des marchés c'est ce qu'on
appelle les économies d'échelle comme on
passe des commandes en volume beaucoup
plus importante les entreprises ajustent
leurs prix plutôt à la baisse et c'est
ce qui génère ces économies qui permet
de faire que ce service qui est un
service de proximité reste un service de
proximité tout en étant globalement plus
économique pour nos deux budgets
si je prends un exemple qui en terme de
travaux de voirie
le fait de travailler ensemble et de
passer des marchés en commun nous avons
économisé 15 % entre l'an dernier et
l'année qui a suivi
concrètement en 2021 et comme chaque
année trois grands domaines
d'investissement mutualisé entre les
départements
l'entretien et l'exploitation du réseau
routier départemental qui dispose d'une
enveloppe de 12,9 millions d'euros
l'archéologie préventive avec 630 mille
euros prévus et enfin l'adoption avec
147 milles euros
un projet ressort quand même par rapport
aux autres c'est la maison destinée aux
autistes
un projet qui selon le président du
département des hauts de seine est rendu
possible grâce à le pays et ça c'est un
très beau projet que nous voulons pas
mener individuellement et qui va
permettre à de nombreuses familles de
pouvoir avoir leur enfant encore à
proximité plutôt que de partir en
belgique
la question reste la suivante les deux
départements vont ils finir un jour par
fusionner une interrogation qui pourrait
être l'un des enjeux des prochaines
élections départementales en juin
prochain
il y à un peu plus d'un an ile-de-france
mobilité mobilité pardon lancé v-league
aux locations une offre de location
longue durée de vélos électriques par
exemple à la vélostation de saint
quentin en yvelines
on peut profiter d'une offre velits go
et hier matin en visioconférence les
équipes présenté trois nouveaux modèles
d'équipements
et faisait le point sur cette première
année de location reportage de mélanie
poppy triporteur d'ipo retard ou
rallonger pour 2021 v-league location
propose trois nouveaux modes de
transport 500 vélos à usage personnel
tango joindre à la flotte de location
qui avait transporté vos enfants dans
son panier des animaux des courses ou
des petits meubles pour aider des amis à
déménager ça se fait sur des trajets
assez varié ça permet de compléter des
trajets donc vous pouvez partir de chez
vous déposez vos enfants elle à votre
travail
puis le sens renard faire des courtes
donc ça nous laisse très polyvalent
faire découvrir aux franciliens le vélo
électrique à moindre coût l'on sait il
ya un an les services met à disposition
dix mille vélos classiques les locations
peuvent aller jusqu'à six mois renouvelé
trois mois progressivement 5000 vélos
supplémentaires sont en train d'arriver
au courant de l'automne et 5000 vélos à
nouveau vont arriver début janvier
jusqu'à février mars 2021 ce qui
permettra d'atteindre 20 mille vélos en
termes de flotte de zelig aux locations
aujourd'hui on a 95 % de nos usagers qui
sont satisfaits du service qui a mis en
place les préinscriptions pour le
triporteur ont débuté hier mardi 15
décembre
les souscriptions pour le bi porter et
le rallonger débuteront printemps 2021
la location de ses modèles coûtera 80
euros par mois pour une durée de trois
mois les comptes de campagne d'ali
rabais mail de trappes sont ils en règle
hier soir le conseiller d'opposition
othman nasri a indiqué dans un
communiqué que la commission nationale
de contrôle des comptes de campagne et
des financements politiques a décidé de
rejeter les comptes de campagne d'ali
rabais de son côté ce dernier conteste
cette décision
sa liste pour que tu rappes respire a
indiqué par voie de communiqué que la
commission a considéré que les actions
réalisées par l'association coeur de
trappes présidé à l'époque par ali
rabais devait être intégré dans le
compte de campagne notamment la
distribution de masques en tissu ou
encore de kits pédagogiques selon le
communiqué toujours la commission aurait
jugé que le maire de trappes aurait dû
pendant la période électorale
adopter une attitude beaucoup plus
réservés ce que la liste pour que tu
rappes respire
fûtes ce sera désormais au tribunal
administratif de se prononcer sur cette
affaire est toujours à trappes à partir
de demain et ce jusqu'à samedi soir la
ville fait la fin de l'année l'événement
tous aux fenêtres remplace les
traditionnels féerie de trappes jeudi
vendredi et samedi soir il faudra se
mettre à sa fenêtre de 18h à 20h pour
observer les déambulations la première
adjointe de la ville nous en parle au
micro d'astrid bergère
[Musique]
pour trois jours nous aurons des
déambulation sonore avec de la musique
des déambulations lumineuse avec des
acrobates et des jeux de lumières et
puis nous aurons aussi à un camion qui
va se dérouler dans dans la dans la
ville avec là aussi des programmations
musicales
nous avons aussi organisé un grand jeu
qui aura lieu qui s'appelle trappe
mission polaire qui est en fait un jeu
d'énigmes qui aura lieu entre eux fameux
risque
et puis le quartier de l'aérostat donc
tout a été organisé pour que l'on puisse
le faire en famille on puisse le faire
entre amis
l'idée c'est un parcours qui peut durer
un peu moins d'une heure et qui va
permettre de découvrir aussi la ville
autrement de répondre à des énigmes et
puis tout est fait pour que les gens ne
se rencontrent pas aussi les parcours
sont bien sûr sécurisé et lors de ce jeu
les participants pourront apercevoir le
père noël qui sera bien sûr présent
c'est la fin de ce journal merci de
l'avoir suivi l'information revient
demain dans le 7-8 journal présenté par
grégory canal et à 18 heures d'ici là
vous pourrez revoir cette émission et
toutes les autres sur notre site
internet tv 78 points comme ou bien sur
notre application mobile tv 78 et d'ici
là je vous souhaite une très bonne
soirée
[Musique]